did you just come with me [ __ ]
and she runs out you can hear them
saying this
wait hold on you can hear that she runs
out of the room completely naked
well save this for them recording that's
great
the simpsons
what did she do you should go to the
bathroom and try to douche herself i
don't know then she like slowly walked
out still naked and i'm like
oh
okay
i'm glad you're really confident with
your naked
you're getting [ __ ]
glimpses of naked bodies even though
you're not they're really [ __ ]
i mean i hey hans [ __ ] okay
i do i do but you get you got free love
buddy good job thanks gary no problem
you get three looks
i don't i don't care about looks i used
to do figure drawing you should have to
look at naked people all the time
better than nothing you ever seen
no i didn't enjoy it did you enjoy
watching like i don't know a naked woman
i feel like i'm i'm kind of desensitized
to nudity that's sad that's sad you're a
bad you're you need to work on that you
need to be happy about naked people
again
make a few let's just people with their
default setting
yeah they're supposed to be sexual if
you don't find that sexual there's
something wrong with you there's a lot
of things wrong with me but i don't
think that's one of them no man there's
nothing wrong with you dude you're good
not finding naked women sexy
wait are you straight
you want to recant your gay confession
while we're okay
how many back and forth did he do
where's
[Applause]
this isn't going good for gareth already
you don't want to go first
no it's your turn
it's a game of three so actually going
first is very beneficial
all right nine
it's also not that beneficial
where did the lighter go
gave it back to you after i let that
cigarette where you gotta roll again
oh it's right in front of me
i got it
that's a hard one
jesus nine then eleven
you go first okay
dude that [ __ ]
creek
how was the
how was the late show how was the turn
up for the late show
there was about 30 40 people there
wasn't that
30 40 that's a bunch
yeah that wasn't bad
is that a bunch
30 40 yeah
i don't know how many people we had
but who had more people
um
was there for that show
yeah
okay
she was [ __ ] hammered when i was
earlier tonight that wasn't
had just gotten off work
i had like three beers and one home did
i bring my [ __ ] hat inside i didn't
see you with the hat yet
do you want to wear a hat are you cool
i'm going live right now look at what my
hair looks like right now i look like a
fish your turn
i don't know what to tell you
so who had the bigger it was about the
same
it's about the same yeah dude that's
crazy because uh when it first started
there weren't that many people there
from what i saw
the more people started trickling in
well bianca's show went from like two to
ninety in like a week i don't know what
happened what i mean people yeah like
her [ __ ] show at the creek do you
think you can fit literally in that room
they sold 100 [ __ ] tickets for bianca
for bianca
tonight but like two weeks dude that's
awesome yeah it was awesome it was like
it went from having two
to like steady four
and then like
every time i've gone there like after we
get off thursday like there's been a
good amount of people dude she puts on
shows all the time she put on shows at
the native hostel she put on the show at
the vulcan so people like know she's
like a show runner exactly
and then she has a built-in audience
they're like oh let's go watch a bianca
show
it's a good show to watch right i mean
dude it's a great show dude she learns a
good [ __ ] she's a go-getter that's why i
want to pair my shows right after hers
i'm like hey i know people are going to
be here
let's [ __ ] see if we can get more
people to stick around yeah i mean it's
great rising tide lifts all boats
[ __ ] i hate you all so much
[ __ ] you too gareth
yep it's your [ __ ] apple watch
you were [ __ ] something to say about
it was watching
apple can't watch from your apple watch
they can only hear
mm-hmm
let's figure it out in the future
you know some more top off how was the
vulcan show i heard the audience was
kind of weird tonight
no i didn't go to them they were they
were like pretty decent for the most
part like
in the water okay oh [ __ ] yeah like uh
where's my what'd you do
oh it's over there on the counter [ __ ]
you by the teddy grahams
because you should if you ever start
rapping be like a teddy grahams but a gr
ams
[Laughter]
grams of weed for a bear
are crack cocaine dude
are there south korean curious dealers
no dude
south korean crack dealers are like
marijuana dealers
marijuana is like super illegal there i
noticed he didn't finish his drink he's
trying to get us drunk so he can
assassinate us oh dude he didn't need
any help with that
he didn't [ __ ] me up right now
yeah i only had a workout with him one
time to know that i was like i am so out
of shape and i have not been a gym in so
long all my favorite tattoo artists are
from south korea so i'm like if i ever
go there really i'm just going to spend
all my time getting sticking points
below no i don't have any here you don't
have any either me neither do you have
any tattoos no that's oh cool man look
at us clean
we were raised right that's what that
means
no i'd get tattoos if like i mean i
wouldn't regret them in 15 years
my friend got a tattoo
right above his dick that says money
over [ __ ]
right right above this that's the type
of tattoo i would get from my first
tattoo i'd be like no just
dude he also has 14 felonies so
uh i've got 14 felonies
did you get them in the span of like
eight months
by chance
because i think my friend did
that's uh you should have a rich daddy
dentist i got them in the span of nine
months i just kept beating the [ __ ] out
of my pregnant girlfriend i went to san
diego
you know in san diego the only thing
happening
dude can you like oh my god work on your
grip strength
the only thing happening in san diego
the only thing happening in san diego
was like this one club
okay and all the open micros just went
there there was no hope there was no
future the best you could do is like
some shitty show at the week on the
weekends here
the vulcan death squad show the kill
tony there's like hope and invigoration
running through this scene
no i i got a buddy in san diego who
moved out there from detroit his name is
uh tim hill and he brought one of the
shows from detroit it was like a heckle
show
there and he started at a club what was
the club called
ben san diego yeah i don't want to say
it might have been the same one but yeah
pick up your second settlements i
haven't gotten my second time i got mine
so i need to put mine down so i lived in
san diego for two years you're gonna put
your second settlement down
no
i mean i just did mine i just did mine
dude
no
he's the last guy so he has to go twice
and then we have to go
so we have to take ours back now because
gareth was a lazy dumpling oh wait he oh
oh we do i'm not
lazy i'm just a dumb [ __ ] just
call me the idiot
write pronouns put back your [ __ ] and uh
let him have like his all right
okay yeah
i could you want to keep it pissed off i
was on your side
honestly
all right fine hans i'm done with you
if you don't want to be like that then
that's fine we'll figure this out our
own self
why is he going last you have to go
twice
yeah you know what i am okay
what am i gonna do about it
we'll figure out
hans i was okay with us just keeping it
the way it
was yeah i mean it looks like it's going
to be that way now
do you want to go back to the way it was
do i go back to the original way
would it all matter all that much
all right you know what
i'm going the other way nice
thank god we did that
it's the same except balls road isn't
pointing to me now
go ahead blow
it's your turn
it's just being rude to me
wait did we get we get the resources
from our settlements yeah it's your
second settlement
just the second one yeah just a second
though
so what were you saying right before i
[ __ ] everything up apparently
uh eight
it's a better scene here than other
places yes it was a good conversation
topic
um
wait i'm not green i thought i was
kidding for a minute
i uh i ran into this guy
yes sir
so ran into this guy on 6th street
and 6.
i brought him and
nothing
uh two of these other people he was with
over to the creek in the cave and
for me
uh
nine i'm gonna need okay never mind for
me what he said he was like oh like this
is crazy he was a big he came here
from orlando
and his brother told him to go to the in
my turn i needed one of the uh
conversion cards
uh
it's your turn we'll get you one
granzi
he uh came here
from orlando his friend told him to go
see kill tony got him a ticket he went
to go seek out that
and i was talking to him outside
only ten yeah you're right i took him
too
to the creek in the cave
and he was really annoying and he was
this drunk lawyer guy
and i was like
and uh he was just like no but i love
the energy here like there's like
something happening
10
10.
yeah
i felt the same way i was like no for
sure like everything we do might be
elevated into the national conversation
so there's more importance behind what
we're saying
for sure absolutely i would completely
agree with you do you guys ever rape
anybody reroll
say that again you guys ever rape
anybody
yeah all the time nine right nice
no i i what about you hans
you ever uh you ever rape anybody yeah
um i think it's a good scene i just
think that
a lot more people need to move here
yeah for sure it's a great scene because
it's like it's got that upper echelon
if your comedy scene has a ceiling
then the comedy it trickles down
but if your ceiling is high
then you uh
you go it might turn up [ __ ] your
garrison so uh
everything else gets better the open
micros get better the [ __ ] mid level
features the headliners it's like it's
it's better to be in that place
where your mind is open and available
and future progress is possible
i totally agree with you man and
whenever i started doing comedy for me
it was like if i don't start doing it
now i'm not my turn here
this is a fresh energy this isn't
happening in anywhere else la and new
york are like they have more shows and
they have more talent but
they don't feel the way we feel yeah the
thing when i was in new york was like i
feel bad right now we feel good it was
like first of all like i mean a lot of
the city was like shut down so you're
doing comedy and like carts on the
street what's this uh for what brick
good man i don't have any break
thank you
but also like i mean a lot of shows you
need tv credits five
i'm in my turn
new york is very exclusive and
it's all about favoritism and all the
old guard you got to respect the
infrastructure there 11. and that's fine
but
um
it's not you can't advance as quickly as
you can in other places would you like
to trade a wheat for anything
i don't need weight
no i meant the other way around
you have rock i do have rock you want to
trade a week for rock
sure
there you go
i'll end my turn
well i mean you're from everywhere else
i'm so happy that y'all are here and i
can call you all my friends and
i got to start comedy and do it with uh
yeah i'm not
you really think i'm a redneck dude yeah
you're like so primitive you're like oh
capitalism it can actually
two does anybody have anything oh i do i
have a brick oh now we know how to get
the brick
look at this [ __ ] capitalist pig
let's divide that break into three
pieces
hey hans by the way my
friend's girlfriend got really mad at me
she sent me a bunch of hateful messages
she's like
four
green robes were missing from our katan
set
so
do you have those extra green roads by
chance maybe
okay you got friends
uh it sucked my dick boy
you [ __ ]
yes i have friends are you done i'm done
go you [ __ ]
dirty [ __ ] did that sound squirrely
all right
12. that's what i figured i was more
brick for you
hey maybe
it doesn't work look at all my work
going to gareth getting [ __ ] break
gary if you want to trade break for
anything you need something what do you
need what do you need karen do you have
stone
yeah do i have wait a rock you mean
i call it or it's actually called or
technically well do you need ore i'll
give you an ore for a brick
give me two ore for one brick no i won't
do that give me an ore and a wood
for one brick [ __ ] no i'll give you one
for a brick you piece of [ __ ] what about
a two for one no i'm not doing two for
one
i was born at night but not last night
garrett
all right okay hold on a minute
stop trying to juin yeah gareth i know
your tricks i was in new york jews don't
technically accept me that's the thing
yeah neither do the
nobody introduce anybody
that's the thing
is three
three all right oh hell yeah
hey
eight more hay
you can have this
uh do you want okay i'll take this and
we'll put some over here
is there anything crazy that happened at
the creek tonight what's with that guy
that's the i think he's brazilian or he
said the bow tie
yeah that guy needs to die in a hole
he's so
toxic he needs to shut the [ __ ] up
because he just represents the basement
like the bottom he like is the [ __ ]
oh the guy that talked during your
experience dude no that guy needs this
guy wait the guy that's talking yes he's
like he represents like the depth of
insanity and it's like it's not good to
have that around no i will literally go
out of my way to [ __ ] on that guy what
is it like [ __ ] bow tie
and like he just doesn't get it it's so
weird because like i talked [ __ ] to
people like okay like everybody thinks i
hate them that i don't hate with that
guy like i do hate
and he doesn't know it
is he funny i haven't seen him no he's
not he's not a comic he just he's just
there
uh
yeah that guy is like we're going to use
the food that's crazy like we shouldn't
have that like we should we should kill
him you guys are horrible
the guy that fought or wanted to fight
louie was it that the guy that was on
mushrooms dude i don't know why [ __ ]
the creek doesn't kick that crazy [ __ ]
out like that's not good what's his name
i don't know
he was uh he was actually in the creek
yesterday on monday i'm going to build a
road no he was
throwing his jacket around and yelling
and then all the cars no i was there
i went there monday and then like he was
still he was still he was heckling every
person that went up and like i was like
one of those guys he's like one of those
guys at comedy shows that just wants to
be the one making a different noise
all right um i was like dude you need to
shut the [ __ ] up like you know and then
he just didn't get it so he just kept
[ __ ] on him
and then i went out back to smoke a
cigarette he was gonna kick that [ __ ]
out like it's not good to have that [ __ ]
around no it's not it's [ __ ] cancer
all right
he doesn't produce he doesn't contribute
anything he doesn't do comedy well the
other guy i'm legitimately worried to
shoot up the place three
um give me whatever i get i think i got
a break right
what are you doing over there nothing
oh my god this guy's are you raping so
this is why gareth is raping someone in
the corner such a [ __ ] paranoid
little [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
you feel free right now you [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right let me see
uh what does he get what does he get
he's green you're green you're good you
get something
a nice south korean woman i will stay
there
i don't know i will stay in south korea
dude that's all i'm asking dude you guys
are [ __ ] by the way what do you mean
i'm gonna win for sure
just looking at the board
oh you didn't do the scoreboard let me
do the scoreboard real quick
i [ __ ] hate you once
three years ago okay so i get something
okay it's four to two to two
i don't get [ __ ]
tensers
what color are you i'm gonna have a red
green and then i'm gonna play my knight
you got a 10 yes sir
e is your
[Music]
uh
me i am
before each one of these
that's so gay dude why is that gay
because you want that broken door all
staring
it hans i'm saying nobody knows us you
could just be like
here's the wild gara you guys still have
two points yeah we both have two points
you guys are gonna lose we're not gonna
lose no seriously you guys are gonna
hear my knife just
a [ __ ] would you trade a hay for a stone
or ore um do you have a stone i need a
stone oh no no no what about a wood
i will trade you
i'll trade you a hay for wood
um
[Music]
yeah competitive
[ __ ] you so much hans oh my god dude
all right i want to trade uh
wait it's four to one right the uh yeah
okay so why is three been rolled so much
i'm gonna trade four hey for one break
iron
all right
i'm going to end my turn there you go
what do you think about
all the crazy gary's gonna kill us dude
what are you doing this is too frequent
no man we're good
it's a three-man game of guitar
we're getting
six do you have what time do you work
tomorrow
5 30 p.m
oh okay it doesn't mean i want to
[ __ ] die tonight well apparently i'm
going with han solo dallas tomorrow so
you're gonna you're gonna put up with
this for [ __ ] two hours
huh i don't give a [ __ ] i love hans do
you know how long it is to dallas you
don't even know it's a tournament i just
did a show asking gareth the guy that's
literally i did the same thing
with that guy that got the answer wrong
is it two and a half hours it felt like
three hours ten i think i didn't know
a couple weeks ago
ten dude are you even a texan which room
are you guys doing
club no there's two rooms in the club
that's what i'm saying i just play the
bigger room
we did the bigger room the one with the
long ass with justin yeah
nice
yeah dude that was a it was just like a
it wasn't even a stage it was just like
the lower part of the stadium it's
stadium seating it was like a plank are
you done i am yes
i apologize is this yours
yeah thanks for looking at it
take care of your cards
put this in your pocket
six no that's that's all this away
should be laid out six
guys
yeah i get it
gareth you got a sheet six
you get a sheep right
shut up boy i smell like matches in here
that's my butthole
what's this stranger smelling butt hole
you've ever smelled you're all the six
yeah why do you get a sheep
because he's here that's a nice
oh [ __ ]
dumbass oh stupid
all right wait wait did we cheers and i
didn't drink i'm sorry i said salud and
then uh hans had already drank his drink
and i just drank it by myself so you
guys both have bad luck now
but um no it's just me all right i'm
going to build up
oh my god okay i'm going to build a road
all right
to your mom's house
so do you all watch the uh boba fett
yeah i just saw the most recent episode
not a fan
i don't like how [ __ ] is it
what you didn't like the band of warrior
i love the megalodon i hate the
mandalorian
did you watch any of the newer episodes
no
this trash it's such trash tv it's not
even there's no thought behind it
there's no like deeper meaning it's just
watching this guy be cool john fairfax
favre
whatever
10 i have nothing
me neither
i have wood
hold on
my turn
right yeah that has three points because
we all know that now
okay okay i gotta put it in this shift
in the high gear here
oh you gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ] me hold
on
it's a hans kid podcast catching this
i am
entering my drone
[Music]
right now i'm actually not drunk
that's because
i got given no one does that anywhere
do you have any wheat do you like to
trade
can you breathe what do you want
let me get it still
i'm worried about you
did you get alcohol in your nostrils no
dude you have no idea are you really
worried about it
what about you what about uh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
i'll tell you some sheep dude i'll give
you a sheep man
that's why you're my best friend
[Music]
i need my order man come on you wanna
give me a shape
you wanna be come here come here
okay
i'll give you the arm okay
[Music]
you whispered the same thing you just
said out loud twice but okay i'll give
you the order
all right i'm gonna end my turn there
you go
you're coming to my house are you seeing
your south
carolina okay
what is wrong with that
this is the only reason that you're here
you don't have to say that hans is that
really
what is your motivation i mean if you're
not i'm looking at the board i
kiss
[Music]
i knew that
i knew that
you know uh
wow i've really traded you a hay for a
sheep right now uh do you have a hay and
you need this sheep i need a sheep i
just offered you a sheep for the [ __ ]
i mean i have so much hate dude i do too
that's why i don't [ __ ] need it i i
offered you a [ __ ] cheap last round
oh i will trade you anything all right
dude
holy [ __ ] do you have an over guaranteed
you think i'm off the rails
no i'm not how about they're gonna lie
shut up hans how about you shoot for an
award so mark
that's it i'll give you a sheep for an
award
okay
okay give me a sheep and
get what i
[Music]
let's just
[Laughter]
we're still on the same team it's just
about yeah
stop [ __ ] dropping i have the gods
you guys don't have the best all right i
got uh ten once more
ted
all right you don't know i have three
points han
gareth
i
okay you know what you slept you know
what yeah let's just say that i'm gonna
build a [ __ ] city let's just say i
didn't need you gareth let's just say
that mark normand oh wait i actually did
tell me about mark norman do you want to
tell us what specific moves you're doing
like if you're building a road or a city
like it's really important that we know
right actually i see it
right just tell us like random details
about the intricacies of katan instead
of having one what do you need a
conversation about one of the greatest
comedians that ever lives and i need a
sheep
i will give you a wood and a sheep
can i finish my sentence no you can suck
my dick and balls you want to hear about
martin luther normandy do you want to
hear about russia i don't want to hear
[ __ ] about mark norman
because you don't know
you weren't in that green room i got
friends i want to know
me i'm right here oh you you think we're
friends buddy you're you're ignoring me
i could tell you something i'm shooting
i'm kidding i wanted to keep to keep
going
through against one eye
so mark norman
let's just say that
god my hair looks so bad oh you guys are
[ __ ] [ __ ] i want to hear this man
no mike doesn't remind me he is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] hell
what
i did not know this oh no idea
i have no idea it's crazy how you guys
are acting like this this is just like
old information
it's all to me i got friends who opened
for me
but also you might not want to say this
on a live stream
oh yeah no one wants to be known as a
pussyhound yeah dude
how embarrassing [ __ ] him he's just
what he's a boy
he's a [ __ ] harlot yeah he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about
his [ __ ]
what i don't know but sometimes you know
you got a girlfriend you don't want to
[ __ ] uh mark if you watch this
because a hunch i ain't saying nothing
i'm just saying
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] out and like i saw
this
saying don't taste on a [ __ ]
livestream the funny thing is that i'm a
huge mark norman fan and are you know me
too
i know that's why i want to go for it he
doesn't anymore yeah dude i didn't i
didn't [ __ ] show this old one like
back in new york yeah that was probably
a long time yeah can you tell him i love
him
but yeah i mean he is let's just say
he's uh legendary [ __ ] you guys yeah
tell us are you gonna buy a road or
something no no no it's um i already
bought a city it's right there look at
how beautiful it is
thank you for joining my point me and
gareth it's time now so that's way
better than me telling you about
marketing i'm going to buy them no i saw
it like i was upstairs like i was like
about to tell people like hey stop
talking i'm like oh they're talking to
[ __ ]
red light is here yeah yeah
you know you can't do [ __ ]
yeah you could say it's pretty
interesting
well no i would say uh that hans i'm so
happy for you like dude getting to be on
that lineup the other night i was like
holy [ __ ] i'm not only seeing
mark norman
[ __ ] shane gilles joe rogan [ __ ]
tony hinchcliffe
i was [ __ ] stoked
i'm so happy were you there
gary you were all so [ __ ] really good
dude you were [ __ ] right up there
dude no you always [ __ ] right
[Music]
it's like on my to-do list
hey
i really give it my 110 on those
let me just like not
you know do the things that
you know i can like be like i don't want
a bomb this time like i bomb it's good
to bomb because otherwise you're not
trying new [ __ ] but there i'm like let's
try not to bomb
and it's good to have that gear where
you're like you're reliable
because that's all that gig is it's
reliability but hans i feel like it's
not just because you're asian as you've
said before that you got put up on kill
tony it's because you [ __ ]
have ambulation skill you have so dude
that's what you said it's not only on
the seal but you have the ammo to go
with the skill you're not just like hey
i know what i'm [ __ ] doing up here
but here's joke after joke after choke
after joke like that other joke that you
told killed tony the other night uh i
was telling you about i was like i heard
you say that a couple months ago top
hands joke right i heard you say that a
couple months ago and then a couple of
times and i love that [ __ ] joke that
was the first time you know i killed
tony and i was like
damn
the thing is like i want to tell you i
love you sometimes but then like
gareth like will [ __ ] kiss your ass
like oh i have to [ __ ] on no no no i'm
not kissing hans's ass nobody wants to
do that you literally are
you know what boyle [ __ ] you and you
know what hans needs to like be like my
dick it needs to be the you're the white
part of the yin and yang and he's the
black part what
why because i'm white he's black is that
what it is
there's the black
and then the black there's a white
you know the dots
what are you
look at that dot right there that
represents
the [ __ ] darkness and the like you
and the lightning
what
do you realize how many times i've
watched avatar the last airbender
you'd be definitely in the earth kingdom
do you think i'd be in the earth kingdom
why because they're
slow as [ __ ] it's because they're all
blue oh my god
they're all pictures
i'm rolling are you done no i didn't
start yet because
i've never seen a road comic oh my god
i've never done comedy in another place
i've ever told you and this is like show
comedy on joe rogan it's like a ferrari
it's like a car show it's not like a
[ __ ] dirty ass road gig in a bar
[Music]
walking down the runway and you just
gotta go with the [ __ ] big guns yeah
you know sometimes you're watching the
fact that's right oh that girl isn't
even hot but like i mean she got on this
[ __ ] fashion show so uh
i guess she's hot
apparently
dude if you don't give me some prick
right now i'm gonna [ __ ] kill myself
if i have it i would give it to you dude
i don't
look at look at this guy pretending no i
don't know i'm all about how does your
return from the cons i'm [ __ ] done
this guy this guy's [ __ ] lying to me
and i don't appreciate it dude here's my
[ __ ] cards dude
that's what i have i don't you're so
easy to manipulate seven
i'm trying one two three i don't care if
you're going right we got six cards
[ __ ] [ __ ]
how does it feel
does it feel like eating dinner with joe
rogan or uh ari shafir and mark
who you are
yeah it feels exactly like
[Music]
red
it's three points are you robbing me
i'm figuring it out right now
gareth is that four points
gareth
[ __ ] you gareth
let's go
let's do this bro
don't call me a bro
come on bro thank you asian peaches
you're a bro
you're my friend dude i'm not going to
call you a bro
you're barely a friend how come you
you're a warm body to play katana i'm
gonna kill you come on
hey thanks rob james for letting gareth
know
thank you rob thanks for listening i'm
funny white man there's only one guy
i don't even know what he was responding
to but i know he's right
oh my god there's always gotta be one
yeah anyone want wood
um no
you know what gareth no
no
water in 12. hold on let me see
what is
even this water water
oh yeah that's it
i'll tell you that i'm a [ __ ] expert
at this game dude that's [ __ ] gareth
would you roll six gareth
hey it's gareth go wow
wow
gareth how are you doing garrus
dude some guy you're okay with me the
other night on this podcast
all right i got a
six so
a little seven
[Music]
grazie
all right i'm gonna uh
let me see
[Music]
that's gareth
putting it
the bricks are the lowest they are one
not one dot two dot
so
good luck with that
six
all right i'm gonna you know
anyone want rock
for what we
no don't trade with him don't [ __ ]
trade with him no i'm not gonna do that
do not trade with him gareth i don't
need you to mansplain to me dude
i don't know i don't like your [ __ ]
big energy in here man i don't have big
dick energy i have to have dick energy
um oh i don't need you i don't need you
downsizing your
massive fat dick dude
okay
don't you don't you [ __ ] short sell
me and then i see it and i'm like oh no
that bit off more than i could
uh
[Music]
[Music]
gareth you want to train me wheat for
anything i'm just a watermelon i want
some wheat what do you have
i have wheat what do you need
i need wheat what do you need
i actually i only have sheep
you don't have any weed
no
no
yeah wait i know look at this guy saying
he doesn't have weight okay
look at him lie to me
one card
okay
do you have any brick girl do you have
any prick
i have one sheep
well i'm going to pass
where's the bathroom right now
right around the corner and around the
bend i'll figure it out
what's your room six
six
you want rock
i don't think i want rocks
what do you uh what do you have that
isn't rock wood something what do you
want for what rock
you want rock for wood yeah no
i'm not gonna do it um
i'll give you a sheep for wood you want
a sheep
no
okay well
i guess we gotta wait till gareth gets
back as he's uh pissing
out of his vagina
all right you know vagina piss me
are you buying a [ __ ] another uh
city
so
who's your favorite comic that you've
ever seen like i know i know you have
one everybody's got one
um my favorite comic that i've seen live
at the vault not even live like just
ever maybe shane gillis dude shane
gillis
i like i've never seen him
do comedy until i saw him at vulcan and
i heard about him because he got [ __ ]
canceled but like i see him do sketches
and he's hilarious and i'm like
i need to see this guy who comedy
he's so good he's good at controlling
the audience because
he is one of the people he's one of
those dumb [ __ ] rednecks and you can
speak to them on their level
it's so powerful because he is
like
like it's like with some people it's
like look at me i'm an exotic freak but
with him he's like i am you i am the
like the
lowest common denominator he's in new
york right nicest way possible
of america
he speaks to us he's the voice of our
generation i feel like you're ignoring
mark
no no he's not going to shane goes like
your turn i'm sorry i want to have his
babies
that's why i feel like man
[ __ ] you lighting matches dude use your
lighter don't waste matches
oh my god hey
david tell like david tell is up there
shane ellis
stop stop [ __ ] giving away his bits
we're live dude that his [ __ ]
girlfriend paid money to give me the
navy seal bit
so good dude that that that made me
think like okay this is what i mean
shane phillies needs to lose weight
learn how to type english before you
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] even though i i
love you because you said david tell him
like uh david tell us
but also [ __ ] david tell us like he's
wearing don't worry you've ever seen
davidson wearing two hats
[Music]
like [ __ ] greedy [ __ ] one hat
two
do
go right well you get your [ __ ] prick
buddy yes i do
are you gonna end your turn
stop me take your [ __ ]
i'm gonna play my victory point all
right which we already know
cause han saw it
so
that's all i'm gonna do what do you
think about my intros
for the comics
yesterday i mean i try to keep it simple
and short yeah i thought they were
pretty gay honestly like myself like i
was like
these are to suck their dicks after this
are they doing that in the greenhouse
yeah that's what you're supposed to do
you're supposed to show honor and stuff
yeah
just roast people because they're sad
that their parents grew up on food
stamps
i was like yo dude i get i'd [ __ ]
suck all their dicks i totally get what
is up it was fun i mean i got to put my
own little snake on it you can do like
and just like because honestly
i respect them and all i should do
is to get that respect to authentically
show so it my job is easy i do respect
them all i have to do is get them to
[ __ ]
see that i respect them because like the
thing is
honest fact
the fact that there's normally not a
host because they just bring like every
comic brings the next comic up
and to see you host like these past like
couple shows
and just like bring it in as a skill
yeah hosting is the first lady
eight nine years i've been doing open
mics introducing comics
i understand the vibe i understand the
energy when you see the host come up
what you want to see i've been watching
comedy shows forever
it's been years and years i've just
accumulated
experience and observation and i
try to portray that inside
and then just like portray my true
emotions because that's so beautiful
it's so awesome that all you have to do
is just express yourself
and the fact that you authentically feel
respect for these amazing comedians
hopefully speaks for itself and then the
job is easy
but hopefully yeah i i wanted that to
come across and i don't know the fact
that that's a skill that you mastered
before you like you know it's like
normally host feature headliner like
that's the first thing you have to learn
how to do is to like bring the energy up
for this next comic because it's not
about you it's about who you're bringing
out totally and like you did a good job
with that dude like i mean
like watching like [ __ ]
well you live the [ __ ] that's it i
kind of missed it
like i kind of missed easy are as simple
but it's not even walk through it
because like yeah watching like i mean
every other rogan show it's like
normally the comic that's on brings up
the next comic
and like
i kind of missed the like the art of
hosting and just like [ __ ] just
riling people up and they get excited
when you say the name and they just ah
you know that yeah you were able to do
that and like
nice i liked that dude yeah i mean also
some of them could have been better
like the shane gillis introduction on
the first night
i kind of stumbled through my words i
didn't see it dude the first one well no
i said
like i see things like but also the same
time like i gotta watch the crowd and
make sure they're not [ __ ]
talking and [ __ ] through the show
but when you're like
it's um i think your turn
it's not my turn i passed i didn't pass
it on i did oh i thought i passed it
never mind i'm mistaken it might be done
because we drank a half a bottle
[Laughter]
dude
but yeah i mean i think it's it was a
great show
[Music]
my job was easy
and i just have to let that energy flow
through me it was great you know
sometimes i [ __ ] up but it was cool no
the only way you could have [ __ ] it up
is if you like stop the energy like if
you [ __ ] were so bad at hosting that
you [ __ ] just people like
it's
fine no but it's so yeah it's not it's
not hard
like i mean it's just like you gotta
[ __ ] just just take the torch and
like keep it lit and that's it you did
you did great and don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
what i think was awesome about your set
was that you like literally stood
up there with toe to toe all those
people that i've watched
like thanks
man you were right there man
i mean that's all you could ask all
right well i'm gonna blackout
can't be the funniest guy on that show
but you're up there with them and that's
that's all you need yeah it's like dude
the show was
it was the same crowd the whole night
and they left
and what you did as hard as they left it
was someone who'd been doing it for
[ __ ]
you know people they they they would
look like this is a very difficult wow
why are you looking at that validator
why are you lifting
his [ __ ] why don't you lick my
[ __ ] gareth no
[ __ ] you blowout you just were talking
[ __ ] to me about
15 20 minutes ago for the same [ __ ]
and now here you go someone's got to
keep him grounded garrett so yeah i'm
[ __ ] grounded oh you trying to keep
the ground you're on the scene you can
say that why give me the [ __ ] wrong
thing
[ __ ] you
all right
and it's like
so there was like a moment in the green
room where did gary did you get your
rock [ __ ] did you get your kids go
did you get your rock it's a six you
dyslexic piece of [ __ ]
you're smoking my dick and balls are you
done just because you're white doesn't
mean you're smart
dude i have a degree don't tell him that
yes there was a moment in the green room
where joe rogan was like how much time
how much time has he done and i was like
four minutes 52 seconds
and i was like i've been training for
this moment my whole life
and uh it's just like
that's that's pretty this is that's been
it's like you know like to them is
nothing is a big deal because everything
they've already done everything two but
the only thing i can bring to the table
is my fresh perspective and excitement
and youthful energy i want to buy a i'm
going to buy a brand i hope that i can
provide that for them
i'm going to buy something accomplished
and they provide so much
more than that for me no it's more than
that hans van der veen emotion is like
be right back priceless or whatever what
are you doing
oh
dude if you were at the vulcan right now
you would bounce yourself
out of here
[Laughter]
you simultaneously
spilled your drink
and then
knocked over the [ __ ] laptop
you kicked the cable
and yanked the laptop dude
what do you want
tell me more hans i'm so excited to hear
about this dude
wait what are these people saying is
somebody trying to [ __ ] me on this
chat again
you wish
no dude that was weird as [ __ ] i was not
okay with that in anyway
what are you talking about
and also you uh sexy south korean man
i'm gonna roll just tell them what it
was
tell them what it was
six
what do you have
what are you gonna do
did you just get four weights how many
did you for you i got three
you got a six bro pay attention
man don't trust you at all while i was
throwing up in here
i don't trust
her
again you want rock
why did you have to throw that up like a
hero card player dude why did you do
that
you don't understand asians
i
didn't totally i love your culture my
you want this
for what we
would
would yeah i'll give you one no
give it to me don't give it to me you
can't it's not your turn no
just don't do it don't do it
don't do it don't do it
cons is going to win if you do that no
win anyways no you're not don't okay
that's just
you guys are tired don't try don't trade
with this [ __ ] cocky would you would
you roll again
just through that right i already got my
rock um don't trade with him
do not do it below i'll pray with you
the next turn don't worry about it
he's making a pretty good argument
though you know would
you want it
no no no no no
stop blow
to blow out don't you rock i need a rock
no
i'll give you a rock dude i swear to god
okay all right now hans i'm sorry but
the white man told me to do something so
i can't do it
i knew you were gonna bring them up he
was your original master
she [ __ ] you my original [ __ ]
[Music]
oh you know you did
that dude what
right by
the weed station
you mean the cbd station
the illegal legal uh
such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
do you think this is any way to act in
the land i didn't eat lunch with hans
kim jong uh joe rogan imagine russians
watching
look at these tiny americans they are
suffering
they do not understand
people like it every time someone
borrows my phone if someone girls like
who is your phone like they was like why
do you have a russian keyboard i'm like
uh i listened to a lot of russian rap
music because they made it illegal in
russia
and uh yeah russia is [ __ ] terrible
[Music]
i want to go to russia capitalism and
communism
gareth it's your turn gareth let's be
carving this dude yes sir
i want my body on display for 100 years
like i'm london
dude you can't drive home like this
no we're ubering dude
no i'm going to take we're going to
we're going with hans tomorrow wait what
was it called yeah dallas county you
guys doing good dallas comedy club
i'm not doing it unless
hogs can i do it
i love that club i've been there once
did a show there and it was nice
it was nice did you have a good night
was the night magical were there it was
it was an accident they're expecting a
physical realm
the physical realm was not transcended i
have to say no one gave me [ __ ] acid
or dmt
i was pretty pissed because i was like
dude
if like if i was like out and i saw a
bunch of elves in the crowd
i probably done better but
for human beings
who are going to [ __ ] and die
was it a good audience it was actually
like no it was a really really good show
yeah that's awesome dude
i'm glad that you had a good show you
know i'm glad there was a good positive
emotional energy
and i'm glad that justin s and margaret
can book a show because i booked him on
a show oh my god yeah no yeah yeah
that's the thing like he got it because
because of you
because i know
yeah
i'm like he told me the whole i don't go
out of town much because i don't have a
car what did he say
so this is the thing hans okay the
reason why i'm going up with you and
i'll tell everybody
that how many people are watching right
now
um 14. okay 14 people
so
i'm gonna build a uh one of those uh
settlements yeah people talk about it
you don't have to
vocalize every break you make
what do you say because because i uh
i don't know how thankful he is to me
because he never actually said that no
he did that he didn't no he's my
roommate and i know he's very i think
it's because you know he's her old
friend he seemed uh hans he seemed very
thankful
he literally said to me thank god for
hans kill i think that's why no but also
[Music]
he's from the same place i am and like
if he like the thing is like he's
[ __ ] he he's such a polarizing like
[ __ ]
he's a progressive figure
he is from the suburbs of detroit but
the thing about detroit is where is he
from the other i don't know the [ __ ]
name of the city dude i know detroit and
everyone like not detroit but like the
other city that he was from i thought he
was from like pittsburgh or something no
no he's he's from michigan
but no the thing is like people people
say they're from detroit and like uh
they're not but he was one of those
people that could go up in the middle of
the hood in detroit and kill like change
the energy in a room kill and for all
these comedies that are from the city
i'm from the city of detroit i've seen
him [ __ ] [ __ ] you hey [ __ ] you man
like so it's like it's a different thing
like
he might not have said thank you but
know that he's grateful like no
you've just taken that shot that is
disrespectful to my culture did i take
my wheat okay i'm going to take my weed
what'd you wrong hey
okay um hans you're being disrespectful
my culture hey by the way i'm gonna grab
my two sheep you 14 people that are
watching
sloppy dankins guys
this is my boy's shirt
instead of uh instead of doing cocaine
he makes t-shirts so please buy his
t-shirts okay the [ __ ] up okay you
[ __ ] okay rob james said uh he's the
turtle in the head i'm trying to support
a friend that has a problem
i used to have a pet i used to have a
pet turtle and then we like not only
does he have a problem he's an
incredible genius
that's awesome that you can find garrett
stop gassing this guy okay
stop gassing him dude he's one of my
best friends what do you want me to do
i have some importance
seven
seven okay we gotta get rid of uh
somehow
wait um
we need to collude again
it's not even going to be close
okay well maybe after that no i didn't
bother no hold on
i didn't eat the turtle and died we uh
we had a pet turtle and uh we bought
another turtle and then one turtle
killed the other one it like murdered it
and so we had to get rid of that one and
then my uh my little brother was
supposed to clean the turtle tank
because they have to sleep they had to
sleep on land and we had a dock for
but like when we cleaned the tank we put
it in a like bowl of water
and then like he [ __ ] fell asleep and
then like woke up
was there any land that he could land no
it was a bowl of water because he was
supposed to clean the [ __ ] tank and i
was like
so this turtle was swimming
all night until i fell asleep
and drowned
then one killed the other one so we're
like hey he was a murderer anyway
but he was a murderer yeah he who made
him feel like a [ __ ] at the end too
he's like oh i want to swim
but
then i put it in a cereal box and like i
had to take it out because
that was the oldest one but i wish it
was a teddy graham spot
but man dude like but yeah
i mean turtles don't make good pests
they say get an amphibian or something
will make cowards of us all
it doesn't matter how tough you are if
you're tired
there's nothing you can do you can't
just roll yourself to have more energy
even if you're not tired if it's your
time it's your time and it was his time
he was he was fatigued
he he got exhausted
dude
he didn't just die
he he
he petered out
yeah he got to the end of his rope and
then he just
forever for every one of those stories
you hear they were like oh i was on a
desert island i got rescued there's so
many that like you know you just [ __ ]
it just lasted as long as possible
okay the titanic
[Music]
i'm not that good of a hunter
yeah really yeah you're not gonna
survive
enough people you know sometimes you
gotta [ __ ] just uh but what about all
those people like tom hanks and castaway
that can throw a spear and kill his fish
like foreign what about all those
teenage girls that like [ __ ] that was
the best cutscene i'll find fc did i
have that scene where he's like
and he's like trying hey
the thing about epstein's island i don't
know everybody's never seen him throwing
a spear and killing a fish like far away
no no but they're thinking about it the
thing about epstein's island you never
heard about anybody drowning from trying
to swim away from getting raped
[Music]
you're ready to get raped if i was 14
i'd have been like take my [ __ ]
jeffrey epstein have you heard christie
verse bit about it
have i heard her bit about
living on earth because she has a bit
about like if jeffrey epstein was there
with her and her youth
like yeah i would love to [ __ ] a rich
billionaire
uh if jeffrey epstein was [ __ ] me my
parents would have driven me to the
airport to go to his island
that would have been a good move
like the [ __ ] thing is that if you're
economically vulnerable
money is like such a tool that you can
use to exploit people around the scene
so if people are desperate for money you
can make them do anything yes and this
is not a good position to be in fact we
need to
eliminate that i'm from the city of
detroit and it's i've
[Music]
survival mechanisms food and shelter
if we give them just those two things
then people are far less exploitable but
we won't do that because we want people
to be exposed i think it's i think i
think like that but
we shouldn't do that to people we
shouldn't make them feel like they want
to blow out unless you're if you make
food in shelter
unless i'm a communist if you make food
and shelter a [ __ ] privilege
i don't align myself to any political
ideology
my whole thing is is exactly what
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
we need to make people less exploitable
we make people so vulnerable and then we
they're so easy to rape
no because you make people so desperate
for cash they're going to be easy to
rape i don't i don't think like i mean i
make people unrape i've read a lot
it's so sad
dude you could rape someone dude dude
bucks
you have 300 bucks you can race anyone
in the [ __ ] ghetto yeah and like no
guarantee i know you don't want to hear
the words right
right right
right
but no like [ __ ] these white men
don't want to live in the world they
created
no
what i'm saying is it's like yo dude
like no
it's just a [ __ ] weird world we've
lived in society it is a weird world but
it's the world that everyone else has
had to live in the world that white men
created
with all their foibles
we did not create this world
who else did when we're living
what are you just gonna play this is all
hey by the way everything dude i wish
asians were in
i
charge
i don't wish the chinese comedies party
was in charge i wish that we got there
before europeans we could have done much
worse i mean i would we could have leon
trotsky you guys destroyed south america
and north america why do you have to
look at the middle east
dude there's no way what the [ __ ] does
that mean
what is that dude your people
your husband
your history
[Music]
do you think that like maybe
destroying the continent of africa and
australia and dude north and south
america was really worth ipads and
iphones you need to talk to my dad dude
i don't know
[Music]
timeout you guys have a really cool
story for y'all right i say let's take
500 more years
and figure out iphones later but let's
also have like africa
hey
you know like be a continent we can
visit
they know you have a giant wiener for an
asian man and you also ate uh dinner
with
joe rogan they're very
you know who i talked to one time
for like a good amount of time
the [ __ ] that also invented
apple
i just talked to uh
right
okay well i didn't mean that pam that
sounds racist yeah you gotta have
respect
[Music]
watch out he's gonna make you [ __ ]
dude
hi again so
[Music]
i don't know what's happening right now
come out with us
[Laughter]
at this point we should have killed both
the balls
it did look at this [ __ ] it's four years
later look at that fish
that fish is just swimming there
[ __ ]
did you see that okay look at that fish
dude
do you think that's cgi tobacco it's a
real fish dude
[ __ ] through that because i know tom
hanks no he did not talk that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
this is what we're capable of this is
like the mastery of our nature we can do
and now we're working 40 hours a week
just to survive
it's not pathetic
let me put on some [ __ ]
royalty-free music for the listeners
okay and i also need to urinate okay
good i'm fine
the lighter
[Music]
i'm so hammered
[Music]
i'm sleeping
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
that sucked
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
channel
[Music]
me
[Music]
i don't like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know i'm too generous
now i've learned to never help you out
cause i'm done cleaning up your mess
found myself
[Music]
right now
foreign
tom thanks for the fish
which
you were before yeah
i'm so drunk right now
that's a problem
you're right
yeah
i can't do math
it's all about visuals i used to get
paid to do math now i can't even do math
[Music]
and then he kept drinking
oh my god just
put up the toilet seat
okay
my dad totally oh my god my grandfather
told me never trust a man who can't hold
this ketamine
dude that guy's the one that brought all
the alcohol too yeah and like i'm i'm
pretty [ __ ] up but i'm
not gonna throw it
well it depends on what your stomach's
been doing all day like if you ate a
bunch of taco bell
think like a bulimic girl it smells like
he's having a baby
[Music]
no i roll the six i don't believe you
i'm giving you a stone
where does he get his tongue
oh he does i'll be right back
yeah take your time
are you done
one second
do you want to see him lose wilson
it's symbolic
gareth do you have anything you'd like
to trade oh yeah what do you want
um i want some brick
you don't have any brick
huh do you have any brick you'd like to
trade
i gotta
he got rescued
then i will pass
her oh [ __ ]
isn't it crazy that she started [ __ ]
somebody else
i'll be right back
yes
who what is this movie role
movie
six
did you throw up
i did
so
before
what happened in this movie
you got rescued you didn't see it
oh i hate the end of this movie
yeah no
he gets rescued
she dates this other guy
it's fine his life is so different it
doesn't matter who's [ __ ] who she's
[ __ ]
there's a lot more to him than like that
[ __ ]
and i'm sure that he's going to uh
find more meaning in his life than [ __ ]
even if he was with his old wife
he wouldn't be satisfied with her
because he had become such a different
person
i believe in tom hanks
he's a good guy
i think this movie was made to wake
he should have been
out too
just wanted his investment because he
went awesome did he not
it's a good story i mean the whole
production was good the story the
writing what are you guys talking about
boyo is portrayed
castaway was portrayed perfectly for the
people of the 90s to appreciate a
castaway i did love cast story people
don't understand that anymore because
the 90s were a very specific moment and
it captured that mentality in that
moment in time he was watching three
ninjas the other day um
gareth are you okay
good gareth
[ __ ] up
okay
did you uh move it
no he's visiting what is her name holly
hunt
i don't know but i do know that um
happened to you becoming a professor
she was looking for him seven
but she's also not the same person that
she was
one of this is here
all right i rolled the seven
how do you guys have more than seven
cars
i'm so sorry wait are we going back
through the rest uh
seven okay so you have your card
[Music]
wait wait oh they made out
that's what i was gonna say the best
scene is yeah from this and castaway
this she still has a husband but who
cares the life outside of her
she has to go on she had to come look at
the score how do you feel about that
because for me it's like
yeah the reality is that a sad thing
happened and that they're both sad and
that is played out in their relationship
you're never [ __ ] married the
relationship is sad
so the fact that their relationship is
just another wrinkle to the sadness
he lost a lot when that happened and he
lost this woman
do you believe in love hands i do
what do you mean do i believe in love do
you believe that you could lose the
right way to think about it love is all
there is love if without love we don't
exist
um but yeah i mean i'm gonna take god
for me then sincerely delusional and it
can yeah i mean
i just think it's the wrong way to think
about it
but i think that
we are all vulnerable and we're all open
to someone else
and this is just
human nature as we
need each other five
nothing from the earth
i don't think you need anyone i think
you want them but i don't think you can
need a person why is the worst
punishment in prison solitary
confinement yeah for real we need each
other in a deep fundamental way
in a human way but not necessarily in a
way that's quantifiable which is what
you get when you're married
six
it's the strongest version of that and
if you can get someone to be with you
even when you're [ __ ]
no matter what you go through it's do
you have any deep connection
no look at that in my shirt what do you
what do you have it you know you ended
your turn you don't know anything
okay but then there's someone else with
their needs that is in her life that
prevents them from being together
eight
oh you saw a [ __ ]
now i got wheat
i just think that the forces of monogamy
have to be broken so that we can
function and exist as real people
shouldn't believe
what you believe in their social
structures what makes you not believe in
monogamy but because it prevents us from
being real people
if she held on to monogamy this scene
would have never happened
are you done very true i'm one second
we need to function in a good way
and to restrict ourselves in such rigid
boundaries is do you have any wheat that
you would like to trade ancient agrarian
[ __ ]
no
no girl
all right
yeah what you want
what do you want for a week
we are we should evolve past
our agricultural ways
i'm just sticking with one mate i'll
give you wood for that really
there you go oh yeah
look at this this is using the cultural
signifiers of suburbia to portray an
image
like this is an image we're all familiar
with they're using i wanted to trade the
image of the suburbs that we all live in
to portray
a beautiful scene
and now we don't shut the [ __ ] up
you're counting out loud how are you
shut the [ __ ] up yeah why are you
counting out like because i'm trading
there's more important things than just
you by saying numbers
yeah they're using the signifiers of
suburban cultural
moors to like
portray an image of what's going on in
the world
and what's going on in their emotions
and this is like something that we can't
do right now because we're ashamed of
our cultural
place in the world and what it all means
like
they're not aware of the suburban sprawl
white flight all that [ __ ] to them
this is just pure and it's in the
ignorance that they can protect
into an arrangement try to understand
people instead of just going off on your
own steam try to make something for what
other people say
and not just going off on whatever the
[ __ ] that you want to say i agree my
culture is a range of marriages and i
was not on board with that
yeah yeah but this is different
this is a different culture this is a
culture where they're
using the driveway to make a statement
why'd you roll
you can't see it gareth won't do wrong
six
six
so it's just shut the [ __ ] up dude
so they're just using the [ __ ] you
know this is something we're all
familiar with and it's just [ __ ]
amazing that they can use this i don't
think it's that to make a make an image
it is amazing you should make an image
of my dick on the back of you that's not
important enough to interrupt with
they're using this [ __ ] with like
what we all go through to
to paint a picture of the emotions that
this guy is feeling
i'm so hammered
well you might feel hammered because you
made us take like
90 shots
well you're just always in the negative
mode and you just no matter what i say
you'll always find a reason to think
it's stupid so
i'm out i'm trying i'm just gonna go and
do whatever i'm gonna do anyways i'm
here to maintain stasis i'm the morpheus
but sometimes you need to go with the
crazier ideas
no i agree with a lot of your ideas
politically however
if gareth is not gonna [ __ ]
beat the woman to
play devil's advocate i shall what the
[ __ ]
but the level of tension that you're
used to isn't always the right amount of
tension to
have like we're watching a very
emotional scene to be apathetic
is not the correct answer is to feel
this guy's pain
no i felt this pain when i watched the
movie
but you just don't want to go through it
now but you should go through it
whenever it comes up you shouldn't just
be like it's over i don't need to feel
it anymore you should feel everything i
love pain
pain is my favorite
to feel but look at their [ __ ]
relationship
you know like
this is what it comes down to
them just slowly driving up a driveway
and that's
have you ever felt
i felt a lot of different things
yeah and this is a very strong emotion
just to feel that we can just visit and
then come back to our real world and
it's better to do that than to not feel
anything and then be surprised by
whatever the [ __ ] random [ __ ] happens in
our real life at least we can visit them
and then come back to our real
shut the life up dude you hear this
[ __ ] yes man over here like i'm like
the thing is like it's so powerful it's
all fake like i i even if i agree with
you i have to disagree with you because
this guy's here and i'm like okay
i need to be the person what is your
personality after
why does your personality have to rely
on what gareth is doing why can't you
just honestly feel this because it's
such a beautiful why would you choose
not to feel beautiful moments they're
more strong because crucial moments are
gay
no these are [ __ ] powerful gary this
package saved my life thank you like
chuck noland
no this is this is very beautiful and i
love this and like he's holding it with
care and like
this looks like ohio
to me
is this like ohio after they cut all the
[ __ ] corn and now he's meeting the
girl and she it turns out she's skinny
she has a thin waist
she is a beautiful woman
and now she can start a new relationship
with this fun new bright thing like life
humanity this the other people this is
what he missed on the island
is like having
anyone it could be anyone and you can
find beauty in that but it turns out she
has like a nice body
and she has got a thin waist
yeah we're you're talking to her grown
she's in love with the guy and like
you're like oh you're in love like you
guys have been
at this for a while and you're just like
i appreciate that and i i love both of
you you talk to the guy and like he's
also like so in love with her that
you're like
oh my [ __ ] god like you guys are
amazing and like i wish like i know that
i never had this in my life
but
i kind of envy it but at the same time
like i want to do anything i can to
preserve
you guys ability to just love each other
you ever have that
yeah
yeah
yeah for sure and it's like great you
know like it's [ __ ]
because it's the thing like if i talk to
a girl
the thing is if i talk to a girl and
she's not like super enemy then i'm not
gonna [ __ ] pursue it
i'm not gonna [ __ ] try to talk her
into [ __ ] me because like that's not
what i want
it depends on the situation do you want
love han did you just wanna [ __ ]
because everyone talks to you i'm like
oh this guy wants [ __ ] love he wants
to get just trying to [ __ ] his love
is it yeah that's a version of love
just trying to [ __ ] people isn't
unloving and if you just like accept the
fact that like
the fact that you just want to [ __ ]
someone that is
then you open yourself up to different
kinds of love and we just think that
there's only one kind of love but you
know you could love people in many
different ways and we should be open to
all types and just be ready for whatever
the moment throws at us
um
and i think that we could have very
many different ways of loving each other
yeah for me like i've never dated anyone
like i've always uh
every year i've talked to them like i
think i like and then i just [ __ ] them
and i'm like okay this
actually is all i wanted
but
i would never
i don't know like natalie i reached the
point where like i've had so many
one-night stands like [ __ ] so many
people where i'm like just
i want a girlfriend oh it's like game
theory the more that you [ __ ] one person
and then you don't feel satisfied with
that the more you're vulnerable to a
long-term relationship the more you're
in a long-term relationship the more
you're vulnerable to a short-term
relationship
so it's whatever balance that you find
fit for yourself
i mean you're all different
and you can figure it out well i grew up
in a culture where marriage is like the
thing it's always a marriage
and i've had a lot of stuff
so
[Music]
but gareth
are you too [ __ ] up
i'm free bro are you gonna die i'm
pretty drunk too
i'm very very drunk needs some physical
but you do need some water drink some
water you're not going to [ __ ] your
pants later
all right oh yeah
all right
you just roll this garage down
dude
and he has the lighter
[ __ ]
death
i'm going gonna try to find the lighter
no that's not it
i thought i had water in my pocket but
apparently yeah
yeah in the car somewhere i got lost
where's the lighter
look in your pockets this is the last
episode of the book of boba fett where
like he [ __ ] fought a wookie
and
didn't get his head pulled off
and it was like oh we're okay with this
there's a cork on the floor and there's
two cards on the floor
i don't know who they came there's three
cards
i'm going to sweet
it's not me
look at the stickers who had the all the
stickers that scared
his so [ __ ] up right now
gareth
uh reading the comments realizing how
little most people know they're actually
talking real drunk [ __ ] now haha
ashtray annie
that's true what the [ __ ] does that look
like my [ __ ] ashtray eddie no i'm
sorry yeah
[ __ ]
isn't it crazy that animals rely on our
discipline and self-control
and it's crazy that little never mind i
don't want to get into my childhood
but [ __ ] i mean
we all rely on other people's discipline
you know like and uh
even like
in any job we have we're like imagine if
you're a turtle
and your survival depends on this dude
cleaning your tank every week
that's pretty much where we're at like
as as a country
like they're gonna clean my tank they're
not gonna get
an insider trade on us dude
[Music]
they're not going to leave us with a
bunch of homeless people running around
do you know how simple it'd be for a
rich person to change a homeless
person's life
or like infinite almost people's lives
like i mean a billion dollars
and you're like oh you got a cigarette
dude you could buy you buy so many
cigarettes dude
but that's not what they need and that's
like what i try to tell them when
they're [ __ ] oh when i'm working and
i'm like dude
i'll give you a dollar right now like
what are you gonna do tomorrow you're
gonna ask another dude for a dollar
you're gonna [ __ ] ask me to do for a
dollar in 10 minutes or literally
after i give you a dollar
so what what do people need what do you
think is the solution food and shelter
just give it to them
stop making people work for it for
nowadays do you think food and shelter
would stop you from asking people for
other things
food and shelter
yeah
at least and then healthcare
clothes shoes
and then see what we can create
just see
what else are we gonna do we already
have all the robots what do you think
about leon trotsky
i don't really know that much about him
you don't know a lot about him
well i mean vladimir lenin started the
uh you know revolution in russia
yeah
and his body on is on has been on
display until like this day is probably
still on display he's involved
and joseph stalin was kind of like the
muscle behind the movement he was like a
thug yeah
he was good at manipulating in power
yeah and then like leon trotsky like
moved to mexico
and then
joseph stalin took power dude drink some
water you drink some
drink some water and come back don't sit
here drink water
it'll be good for you it will or not and
so again leon trotsky like moved to like
mexico and joseph stone took fire and he
was just like behind the muscle
and um he got
stalin sent some like kgb agents to
murder him with an ice pick and he got
like murdered from an ice pick in mexico
you know what is he talking about
well there's a power vacuum and he
filled it
yeah he filled it too well and
he was
did i roll
i don't think you were old did you
where'd you go
no i rolled because i'm the only one but
what is wrong it doesn't matter i'm
hammered
go ahead roll
is that hammered gareth
did roll
nine
nine
[Music]
are you okay gary
all the fire
dude you got to go back
go back to the toilet dude make your way
there gary before you go to the toilet
can i get a lighter off of you
look in your pocket
outside
he's in the bathroom i'm not going to
run his pockets
i gave him my lighter when we were
driving here
i was sorely mistaken for doing that but
dude these [ __ ] honkies i'm telling
you
we get [ __ ]
[Music]
dude
gareth hurry up dude
[Music]
[Music]
discovery and the shuttle has cleared
the tower
[Music]
retail computers now have primary
control of critical vehicle functions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one
[Music]
so
[Music]
dude are you done
i think so
[Music]
there's a song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
six
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cheese
[Music]
chiefs
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
first
[Music]
yeah
it is your idea you're the one that
poured all the drinks if you do
you over serve
do you want to yourself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
you're one
[Music]
my friends
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
that way i can [ __ ] all night
dude this podcast was great until you
got too [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] ruined it
don't say that to me horns
get your [ __ ] together dude
think positive thoughts
lay down lay down on the couch and
figure your [ __ ] out
no i'm gonna trade a city
one two three four points one two three
four
me again points tell
me
yeah i'm gonna feel it
you feel it
there you go
three
wood
no wait
you two would only
that brick
what i'll give you a week for a break
what i don't need a weight i need a
brick yeah brick
for what
for wheat
what about wood
no what about rock
so nothing
oh
oh my god
i told you earlier i was like hey we
drinking too much yeah that was a lot
dude
just scoot your chair back
and lean lean back
further
three
oh yeah
that's three four seven nine
right here it's three six
nine they're both nines
this one i got another wood this one i
got another sheep
seven
three
seven nine
three six nine
girls role
all right let's just roll into the box
yeah you gotta wait
here
hey
let me turn
yeah obviously
dude back
put this hand away
yes sir
three
two eight
is your turn blow
wait oh wait i forgot to get the wood
two wood
mm-hmm
what'd you do for 589
all right
[Applause]
today was just another day
dude have you seen lei miserable
les miserables
[Music]
i'm sure it is have you seen the world
of tomorrow by don herzfeld no
selena miserable is like about like this
guy and he wants to start a revolution
because conditions are so dire and the
people are so poor
and he starts one and then no one comes
and then people like did you see them
die together did you see what they did
did you see how much they believed in
their cause
they wanted a better world for us
they wanted to create
a better world
so we want a better world this isn't
working i'm sorry it's right yeah
yeah
i've been thinking about like i am don
hurst felt like i started kickstarter
like uh last year
and
i just got
it turns out he lives in austin
i never knew that but um yeah i ordered
it like a year ago and like i never put
in my address so i never got the blu-ray
and i just got it like a couple days ago
was you open to like watching gareth
can't handle his shortcake this l gareth
taylor's all gareth is smackhead
whispering gareth's ear dog
blow and said i should be in class man
the loudest person now the quietest
person ever
well gareth i mean i i feel like you're
pretty much done
[Music]
did you have you rolled you rolled right
i did roll it
are you gonna buy anything
yeah
give me a second
i want to buy development cards
rock and
dude when things are dire when things
are [ __ ] up like what are we supposed
to do we're supposed to just take it
doesn't it make sense of stage of
revolution
you got it bro
there you go
how come i can handle it so much better
than he's handling it isn't that weird
me too
am i gonna say anything
dude it actually just depends on your
diet because if you were starving for
three days and you drank that much
alcohol your stomach would be so [ __ ]
it's just all relative it really doesn't
matter i don't think he's been starving
for three days
i highly doubt that but imagine
25 years of eating whatever the [ __ ]
garbage that he's he's been eating
and then combine that with his emotional
state and the hormones that are going
through his body
it's just like
you never know you never know how dire
the situation is
[Applause]
five
he did not dream until today
it's kind of a key that he hasn't been
doing comedy as long as
a lot of people because
he has been used to drinking this much
i think
it depends
well i'm gonna take some of this tequila
then if he's [ __ ] gonna die
if he drinks anymore
[Music]
i'm pretty much on the verge of blackout
drunk but
and this isn't even what is this why is
there a tape
[Music]
the emotions of struggling to fight and
be willing to die
for people that
are struggling
it's a beautiful emotion
and with that emotion with that
knowledge of that emotion that exists
if you have that then the people in
power will always be afraid because you
always have the ability to overthrow
them because you want to die
death is not a it's not a bad option for
you yeah but what about the willingness
to be
able to die for nothing
yeah
that's a strong emotion once people have
that once you got like the people in the
middle east blowing themselves up
like we are so powerful human beings are
so powerful they can't ignore that [ __ ]
did i buy a road
and once we put our minds
to destroying the system that exists
i mean
the the defense is always at a
disadvantage
because there's so many ways to [ __ ]
with the system more than you can
prevent
you're always playing defense you're
always responding to the next attack
if a person wants to destroy your
civilization and your order
they have so many more tools of their
disposal
[Music]
so the only
key to that problem is to prevent people
from feeling the need to destroy your
civilization in the first place
and uh the iraq war
was not a step in the right direction
what about keeping people distracted
from everything
it works for americans but that doesn't
work in [ __ ]
saudi arabia
or places where people are actually done
saudi arabia oil
okay
it's possible right you gotta have the
right mix of intellectual and global
awareness mixed with poverty and third
world desperation
saudi arabia
that's where most of the 911 hijackers
came from they knew the system they knew
how to [ __ ] with it they knew the power
of the airplane
they knew the power of the symbol of the
skyscraper
they had the knowledge
of our society and they had the
primitive desperation that comes with
poverty
and death and destitution
well
we're going to see how this all plays
out you know in the long run
and we're in the long run it's just the
[ __ ] that part
yeah
and we've done all we can to prevent
the inevitable violence
dude we were still trying
america like
america is like [ __ ]
full [ __ ] at the end
we are just built on an inherent
contradiction
america is built on a land based on
freedom but that started with slaves
we've been trying to resolve that
conflict land of the free home of the
slave am i right
dude that makes no sense my
great-grandparents were slaves
dude that kind of that kind of [ __ ]
dehumanization i grew up knowing them
and they're like hey he was like hey you
have my grandmother you're was like
that right
dude we went from bach and mozart
to chattel slavery in georgia
like these are people that were like i
understand modernization
i choose to live like a [ __ ] spartan
with my
cadre of
people that i bought that work for me
that are property
that you they made a choice they had the
option to not do that
but
here we are
regardless
we're falling apart mentally we're
unwell
we can't resolve the inherent
contradiction in america
of slavery
and freedom
is this the land of the free then how
can you justify paying people at walmart
7.25 an hour
it's
there's a weird like anxiety that comes
up with me because like i was raised by
people who know
that this is all very very temporary
and it's all
based upon like my dad was born in 1953
and my grandfather was from alabama in
the south like before then and he moved
to detroit because he was an orphan
and
my whole life it's just been like
like i got drafted because of nixon in
vietnam
when i was in college and makes him like
took away the power of college students
to avoid the draft by being in college
and so he had to go serve
do that
and
it's just
now like after all these years all these
[ __ ] my dad [ __ ] worked at a
company
for 45 years and when he retired he gave
him a lamp
gave him a [ __ ] fancy lamp that's
what you get for devoting your life to a
corporation
and it's like
for me i'm like i never
like i couldn't do that you know like
and like i feel like a generation is
like we saw the suburbs yeah we see that
we see them like this is not
enough
so hopefully i mean you know one day you
know
we were able to transcend this but it's
not looking good it's not looking very
good
yeah because like i mean even like with
with coven inside of training like the
politicians at the uh fresh line they're
like
know
no one trusts the system and it's never
been fair though but we never knew it
like we do now we never admitted it
once you admit it then things start to
fall apart
with comedy like that's a thing like
comedy
is kind of
slipping between the cracks of this
society where you can call out the
[ __ ] [ __ ] everyone knows it's
[ __ ]
but you can't say it's [ __ ] because
you have to go back to your [ __ ]
shitty ass nine to five
and that's what makes you
yeah a functional human being yeah this
is the thing that's worth something
otherwise you go to your job bitter and
angry and then you start spouting off
and then you get fired you have to
delude yourself
and we're all deluding ourselves like
our lives depend on it because it does
and we're furthering this idea that
things are different than the reality
that we all know and feel
we all feel this system we all feel that
it's not working you feel the buddha in
your neck yeah we all feel it and then
you see things like what's happening in
ukraine
with russia and they're like hey
we do better under russia than we are
under the ukrainian government
but also like you look at russia and
you're like oh you're in [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] invading ukraine
what are you gonna do like what's
happening in china with the wingers like
what are you gonna do like what they're
like hey what are you gonna [ __ ] do
the problem is that america has no moral
high ground to be like dude you're gonna
stop genocide yeah they're gonna [ __ ]
with you
stop
ukraine we never had it but now we like
admit that we don't have it because it's
like we have the highest imprisonment
rate we have the 25 percent of the
world's prison population we invaded
iraq
dude the iraq invasion
we now don't have the coalition
of america germany france
england
the year the invasion of afghanistan and
iraq they were like what the [ __ ] are
you guys doing they lost trust in us and
now we don't have a unified voice to say
to the [ __ ] chinese
stop that [ __ ]
we lost the moral high ground because we
were too greedy the thing about china
like i mean honestly like
you can look at them and be like they're
all like you know the chinese communist
party has been like
snuffing out any opposition
over the past you know
60 years
slowly but surely yeah and
i mean
our voice with all these other countries
[ __ ] that it's all like
what what other choices they have
china was under an existential threat
from the west
they had the opium wars they had great
britain selling opium in their country
against their will they had japan go and
rape everyone
they had to
become
a threat or else they would be at the
mercy of western imperialism and like
how that turned out for africa and south
and north america
and the middle east
they
decided that they would rather
colonize themselves and let the west
colonize them
yeah but i mean like
i grew up with a lot of people from the
middle east like directly
because you know
my name is that's where my name comes
from you know
like that culture
and then like my stepmom is asian
she's from
like those islands you know it's from
like in indonesia but she's also
technically asian
and it's just like
like my dad like when he was in high
school he's for a kid from detroit he
got to like
get a view of the world through like he
he won a contest from delivering
newspapers to go to the montreal world's
fair you got to meet people from all
around the planet and it was like oh
wait it's not like this everywhere it's
like [ __ ]
you have different perspectives
this is what he kind of devoted his life
to
so like you want to see what get us up
to
uh probably vomiting
edison
let's go see what gary's up to
puking
i will die in america too rob i will die
here
oh my wait
it's you oh
i gotta go help gareth sorry rob
no i love this country don't don't ever
mistake that but
we are very very flawed
is
is
okay
um
you will
oh
just in case
um
[Music]
well let's finish this game
it's not that important
but you're not that important
yeah neither is gary
dude how did you get that [ __ ] up i
don't know did you drink today
the lights are flashing
did you drink at the creek how much did
you drink at the creek
let's finish this out
no stop it i'm okay i got it
all right below i'm gonna finish it out
all right oh you're at nine and i'm at
five this is like the last game all
right
and
he's just guards around the floor all
right i guess we
should okay
do you think it's too late for us as a
society this is on edge
i have faith in humanity
i don't have that much faith in america
i wouldn't bet on america what's your
favorite country historically
i would bet on the species
what
what's my favorite country yeah in the
pet in the history because i love
history like it's one of my favorite
things to delve into i have no idea
i don't have enough experience with
other civilizations really do you never
delve into soviet russia or uh
literally anyway soviet russia was just
coming off nazi
the nazi threat vietnam no is there so
many russia happening before the nazi
threat it was like the 1920s but most of
their history is after the nazis yeah i
mean world war one after that but i mean
after after world war ii is like mostly
getting over stalin
yeah
the spelling was necessary
stalin was necessary yeah
dude what do you think about leon
trotsky which is what i asked you an
hour ago i don't know
do you not know but it was like after
vladimir lenin like led the revolution
leon trotsky and joseph stalin were like
the two top contenders yeah and um
stalin kind of [ __ ] trouts gilbert
because at uh lenin's funeral like i
guess he got told like a different date
that the funeral was on so
like
but song was also the muscle behind the
movement
and
after song took power like landon fled
to
mexico
and he was more of an ideological
successor
but then he got murdered by the kgb with
an ice pick in mexico
and stalin led to
many many more deaths yeah i mean stalin
was like a
power hungry [ __ ] and he won because he
wanted it more and trotsky was probably
the more
the right choice but he didn't get it
because there was a power struggle
there's a there's a struggle that goes
on with that [ __ ] that if you don't
uh if you don't [ __ ]
admit it and just act ideally then it
will never be resolved and i think that
you have to have both and trotsky was
too
concerned with the art of it that he
wasn't thinking about the larger picture
and that he had to turn into something
that he didn't want to become
do you have any brick that you'd like to
trade no no
but it requires good an
their
idea
and become worse than they are and it's
like where is the end of that like how
do you know when you sacrifice enough
and when you're
sacrificed too much
of your morals it's just not not a very
i mean the the thing is that the
desperation was introduced by western
threats
the only reason stalin had the ability
to gain power is because they were under
threat and they were willing to give
away power for safety
if there was no western threat
then maybe they could have developed
in
uh pristine idyllic conditions but they
were
they were under a firearm
they were being attacked by all the
largest economies in the world this
agrarian society that has never been a
big player in europe
and now they were destroyed by nazi
germany
and now they're trying to figure it out
and now all the world's powers are alive
like there's a movie called come and see
where it's about the nazi invasion of
belarus
and it's on youtube like the full
movie with english subtitles and i've
watched it a few times
gareth shut the [ __ ] up drink that there
and drink the rest of that water
take care of yourself dude why did the
cold war start i would
why did the cold war start the cold war
started because america america was
jealous that there was another country
prolonging and taking the next step in
the experiment that they started they
were the vanguard and now they were
someone else
taking freedom to another level and they
just couldn't handle it
have you seen chernobyl like the series
yes we are
yeah
yeah and
like
if if
okay
what did you trade that for i would
you won yeah
wow no
no he already won he was at nine before
yeah i know he
won [ __ ] goddammit dude
dude you fell apart
i know i felt i'm very well yeah all
right i'm gonna grab these off the
dude floor a [ __ ]
child
are you talking to me yeah i hate you so
much
you got a message from india w and conor
mack
is that good are you sure
india says hey sorry i never got back to
you i was busy with family stuff then i
came to puerto rico but
and then connor max as always
yeah india didn't respond to your
messages
is she
spicy
don't say that man india is probably
watching this podcast
good job buddy
well i'm glad that you're still talking
she's like one of my good friends
i'm glad that you lost your virginity
true love
i don't think i want that i don't either
you're not really talking her up
the best
so anyways
let's get back to politics what is
what is the option is it capitalism or
communism is the world really that
binary
or is there like another option that we
can [ __ ]
what do you think about antifa do you
think that
we require a violent
and primal response to fascism i do but
i think we require one fascist response
to everything
well i mean
ideally we wouldn't have to resort to
that
but
the forces of fascism
are so primitive and so
illogical that maybe all that it
requires is just a [ __ ] force in the
opposite direction
i don't think that would end well either
i think there's a good struggle you know
yeah what do you think world war ii was
dude that's what i would say dude
everybody was [ __ ] after world war ii
they didn't give a [ __ ] about what you
looked like
they were like did you survive let's
[ __ ] now
and that's what happened
that's exactly what happened after world
war ii
hey man
hey brad
right now i
tried but uh
fred hampton
no yeah you're right brad about fred
hampton like uh you know that's why
that's when you get murdered by the
[ __ ]
government
yeah every time you try to [ __ ] his head
all right let's all let's all pay
together you know like that's why i've
never like hey let's hold babe together
i'm just like hey [ __ ] you do you know
just the police the police
our system
oh my god it's gonna work out so well in
america and
yeah free labor
[Music]
lose
[Music]
i think it might have been all the
alcohol you drank
you drank a lot no but i'm usually 100
right now
i guarantee you i'm more drunk than you
right now gareth yeah i'm very very
drunk what's happening
well it all depends on what you ate
beforehand how much you've been drinking
this week
it's just a lot of different variables
but
so there were these girls and they were
strippers
and the owner of the vulcan's dad
brought them all there and on tuesday
after the show
we were all like oh [ __ ] there are
chicks
let's go see what they're all about
they're strippers i don't see what
they're all about they want they're all
about the money
that's all they want from you
so they all we all went out and they all
talked to him ari shafir came back first
and it was like they're dumb as [ __ ]
then
then uh shane gillis came back and he
was like
they're beautiful beautiful ladies and
we should honor and respect them
and then mark norman mark norman didn't
really go after them he was like i don't
i'm not really into like this whole
[ __ ] thing because everyone's so
[ __ ] up now
sounds like a good dude to me
yeah i was like a good dude
yeah and then uh
then the strippers all went away
and then
we were going to hang out but then
you know the the new york boys all went
to their hotel and then joe went home
and then tony and i went to latchkey and
we just partied it up that night on
tuesday oh you wanna i think
yeah wednesday night
we're all hanging out joe rogan was on
stage we were all hitting on the girls
grizzly bot
brought
over by the guest table where the vip
always sit wait hold on what
i don't think so they were no they were
all really hot and i was like are they
strippers
well if they weren't strippers they were
stripper adjacent why
but that's the thing is like that kind
of show brings out different sides of
people that they might not be willing to
bring out in other scenarios but the the
gravity of the situation allows them to
be more promiscuous
but then after that
happened
joe rogan finished his set and then we
went directly to red ash he had put out
a reservation for that and
really like we're all at the mercy of
joe rogan we're all there for joe rogan
if he wants something it doesn't matter
how much we want [ __ ] we wanted to
invite them over but honestly what joe
rogan wanted takes precedence the idea
of momentary [ __ ] is nothing compared
to the career
uh
enhancements that could be provided by
joe rogan
so we all went to red ash without a
question we we didn't even like question
him at all we were like we want to be
with the strippers
and the [ __ ]
but
the joe rogan um
connection is way more valuable
so we all made a conscious choice bro
someone said shane goes to him
i want you to know rob james you're
going to lick my [ __ ] right now rob
james says gareth cat
she's right i'm okay she got something
done unlike us
suck mine so then we all went to red ash
we ate some crazy ass meals
and then we came here and then we parted
away we went through
i don't kiss ass on a regular basis but
[ __ ] you
we went to grandma's bar and then we
hung out and i talked to jessica for a
long time who is jessica she's a
beautiful lady that
i would give up the world for
that sounds disgusting to me i'm out of
here
i don't think she wants me i think she
thinks
who is she is she a stripper is she no
no
she's just a normal person
all right uh we're done thank you
bye guys